[Music]
i have with me david pakman
he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a baby
david patman he is
david patman he is a baby
david patman he is a pain
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but hold whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta look that's a
lot
that's a lot happening with everything
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical
thinking and they're controlled by the
darkness of david pacman
he is a baby
david patman he is a baby
david pacman he is a beta girl
he gave it pacman he is
[Music]
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking bizarre
questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right guys we've got too much going
on to deal with too much of that we are
standing by
for donald trump uh in erie pennsylvania
for another
super spreader corona rally and we are
expecting a lot of different things
today
um i am going to be i'm going i plan to
be totally clear
of the stream uh well before aoc's
among us stream with hassan [ __ ]
uh i don't want to overlap with that i
couldn't possibly compete with that so
we're going to be
very very clear of that no no concerns
whatsoever
and uh in fact i i i have a hard out at
8 00 pm eastern time
so it looks like things are running on
time now it looked like trump just left
the white house a few minutes ago per
twitter
but then i also saw what looked like
trump's plane already on the ground
in pennsylvania so i actually don't
really know what's going on
even though the fox news stream is not
yet running
but we're going to keep an eye on
everything
extremely strongly and
i think we're going to be uh we're going
to all
uh have a very strong sense of what it
is that that is going on so no concerns
whatsoever i have a bunch of different
things to go over with you guys
i will explain the different background
momentarily because that is one of the
items i i did want to discuss today
very quickly just to look at some of the
latest polling there is a bunch of new
polling today
a new florida poll has biden plus one
what does it mean you gotta vote one is
nothing one is nothing
georgia trump plus one and georgia thai
what does that mean we just go and vote
because it's going to be very close
minnesota biden plus five not nearly as
big of a lead as i would like to see
gotta go vote
pennsylvania biden plus three that
doesn't make me super comfortable
time to vote iowa is a tie could be
winnable you've gotta vote
on north carolina biden plus one three
and three
that's too close for comfort you've
gotta vote
ohio biden plus one that's what i call
an opportunity and nothing else you've
gotta vote
michigan biden plus seven uh look at how
how michigan went in 2016. you must vote
kentucky trump plus 17 okay i mean
listen trump's going to win kentucky
but i would still recommend voting
anyway that's my perspective
and very importantly new reuters ipsos
poll has the senate race in north
carolina this is one of the key races
that could determine who
uh controls the senate has it as a tie
abc news says cunningham the dem plus
two
uh east carolina university poll says uh
cunningham the dem
plus one and then georgia senate you've
got a thai and the republican
plus one so you've just got to vote
that's it my friends that is
it i voted over the weekend here is a
video of me voting extremely strongly
um just rocketing my ballot right into
the ballot dropbox
official official official dropbox there
not a mailbox but a ballot drop box it
is real
i got a hundred messages from people
saying it's you know is that am i sure
that that's a real dropbox yes i am
it is indeed very very real and uh i
encourage people to follow my lead and
vote vote vote why not why not
so uh that is the latest as far as
polling
is concerned um
oh my god this video this stream is from
right side broadcasting
they've got 65 000 people watching who
love this crap
they love trump and they're sending 50
super chat
super chats like their penny candy oh my
god
i guess being a right winger is
profitable that's insane
um but let me get to a few of your super
chats ronald wilson reagan says
introducing the pillage people
featuring trump pence mitch lindsey
graham and ted cruz they're sure to make
loads of frothy santorum together
stranger danger says david it looks like
fox is starting to further harp on the
hunter biden laptop story despite the
lack of credibility
what the heckle is going on they're
getting desperate
and jack clark says just dropped off my
mail in ballot
in pennsylvania earlier today love it
love it love it love it great job uh
jack
michael foster says i must commend you
on the extremely
powerful voting david congratulations
well thank you
uh couldn't couldn't do it without you
also a big thank you to sullen soliloquy
and great
graded placebo who have uh subscribed
over on
twitch uh tonight the event is in erie
pennsylvania we are standing by for
donald trump
we will be hearing from him coronavirus
keeping melania from attending melania
according to the official white house
schedule
was scheduled to be at this rally
tonight she is still experiencing
symptoms
and she will not be at the rally you
know she's probably also contagious
which would be a reason not to go
although there are debates as to whether
how long are you contagious and and so
on and so forth but melania will not be
based on the latest uh news i saw
accompanying donald trump because of
corvid as some people are now referring
to it
i do have some fresh memes um let me
start getting some things
off of the list okay what is behind me
why do i have a different background
behind me
i now am the host not only of the david
pakman show
in the english language i'm also host of
a spanish
show on the television network this is
cable now
okay cable um with
uh on the network estrella it is sundays
4 p.m eastern 1 p.m western
okay and right now it's only available
if your cable system
has the channel but in the future it
will also be available
online we we put up a different
background i recently interviewed in
spanish debbie mccarsell powell who was
on last sunday's episode
and i also recorded an interview today
with the los
angeles mayor eric garcetti and we have
something
very special lined up for next week so i
think what i'm going to start doing
is we're going to subtitle some of these
interviews in english and post them to
the english language youtube channel
so people can see them and some big
names bigger i mean no disrespect of
course to eric garcetti who
maybe in the biden administration if
biden wins uh or or congresswoman debbie
mccarsell powell
but some people who are famous from the
standpoint of the entertainment world
not the political world but the
entertainment world may be joining me
um on the spanish show the spanish
show which is a whole different audience
so that is that's that
i have a couple of other things memes
and the like
this was a meme posted to the subreddit
earlier today
are you going to sleep biden is polling
rather well you know
yeah let me just scroll through my
youtube feed once more
david pakman video trump winning mail-in
and early voting in key states
and then you're up then you were up all
night
we it's happened to all of us we've seen
it happen to everybody
so that is a meme that was uh presented
earlier a couple of others that i've got
this is i guess a farmville parody of
when i held up one of my green tomatoes
last week during a stream
uh farmville here is a tomato i've never
played farmville
so i don't know how you guys would rank
this meme out of ten
um don't know if it's relevant to
anybody's interests so there's that one
and then this was really really good
this was actually we have a new discord
and today i just was looking at it and
someone mentioned signing up for a
membership on my website
and land north of the humber
said did you use the illegal discount
and pepe silvia said oh yeah spent three
nights in jail over it those discounts
are very very dangerous
when it says 66 off that's no joke
okay that is no joke whatsoever and pepe
unfortunately jailed
for three nights due to using one of my
immoral
and arguably uh illegal
actually wait no illegal and arguably
immoral discounts i think is the way
that i would say it
big thank you to la daniel de chanel
with a 55 dollar super chat who says i
don't think i can survive part two of
this reality show
it must end november third he will stop
at nothing to become re-elected because
he knows the new york attorney general
is waiting for his ass at the door get
out and vote
keep it up david um wild
wild wild times wild times um
okay what else do we have going on
uh oh okay another a couple other uh
super chats i don't want to skip off
skip some of these others safric gaming
says made the mistake of voting third
party in 2016
today i began my redemption by voting
early for biden well done
james says where do you start with
describing trump to someone i had
someone ask me recently what's so bad
about trump
i was so taken aback i honestly didn't
know what to say where would you start
honestly i wouldn't
uh you're not going to convince those
people if somebody says what's so bad
about trump
14 days out i just would ignore them i
would move on to something else
ryan says dave you voted with great
strength and toughness some people are
already saying it may have been the
greatest vote ever
yeah in fact i sent my doctor
a video of me voting he said he's never
seen
someone vote so strongly um
and he said it uh it doesn't he's not
even he doesn't even want to get he
doesn't need any blood tests he was
going to do a cbc
but then he saw this video of me voting
and said we've doctors have never seen
he actually sent it to uh
the harvard teaching hospital and
doctors were just shocked
shocked that uh shocked at what they saw
all right the fox news feed
is alive as they say so we've got that
going on
um oh uh we had a very strong tweet
earlier
retweeted by the great asha rangapa
and john favreau and a bunch of people
my question was a simple one
can anyone tell me what crimes trump
thinks
biden committed that would warrant
jailing him and
john favreau or actually what was it i
think it was john favreau
um tweeted that
he thinks if trump were pressed to
explain exactly what crime has been
committed
that trump wouldn't it would become
clear trump doesn't even understand his
own conspiracy theory i think that's
exactly right
i think there is no question about that
whatsoever i think trump does not
understand
his own conspiracy theory um
am i taking calls today oh okay
here's something i'm hope i'm thinking
of doing okay
we have the new official david pakman
show discord that's davidpakman.com
discord okay that's the forward slash
currently with 2 200 members on it
we have really bolstered
and emboldened the discord
and we've taken calls through it what i
would consider doing is because we
as i said i have a heart out at 8 pm
eastern time and
we've the audience seems to be pleased
with me not
doing the full rally where we get a
sense of it after the first 20 or 30
minutes
if the rally starts about 7 15 maybe
we'll do a half hour of rally
and then at 7 45 maybe we'll mute the
rally and do some discord calls because
people have been asking for me to open
the phone lines
so to speak and i'm open to it and we
want to boost
the new discord and so on and so forth
so that's something i would consider
doing at about quarter to eight eastern
if people are interested i don't know if
that's something people would like
uh maybe let me know in the chat yes no
maybe so
people unclear about it okay well that's
fair you can be ambivalent
yeah all right well maybe we'll do it
okay yeah we'll see if trump doesn't
start too late and we can get you know
a good 25 30 minutes of rally um then
i'll i may do it and maybe we will even
go
twitch exclusive but that's that's a
little risky we'll we'll see
one person says it doesn't make sense
all right that well that's fair
if it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense but that's what i'm thinking of
doing in any case
let's do a few other super chats what
else do we have going on
ariane lynch says worked for the trump
victory team in arizona and new
hampshire
massive survey fraud is being committed
what do i do email me let me know
exactly what's going on through the
website contact form
n.h bone says david is trump giving in
completely to his rage he's physically
ill he knows he's losing
and he lacks the capacity to understand
why a lot of what you're saying is true
yeah
very much so austin says on that point
is the world watching us like a reality
show or are they enjoying brunch with
their loved ones i think it's both
i think people are watching us like a
horrifying reality
show and gladly recognizing
that they don't live here and thus
going to lunch and having a grand old
time
hugh hundo says what do you think about
the u.s realigning itself
with allies upon a biden election also
i'd like to send you a shirt if possible
my own merch free of charge listen i'm
going to be totally
i'm going to come to you with peace and
love you don't send me anything
okay here's what's happening um i didn't
miss the 55
super chat guys i went to it first i
went to it first so i did people
think i missed a 55 super chat uh but i
didn't i already addressed it
we get so much stuff at the po box
and we it's just like my house is full
of stuff
and i'm i'm a minimalist from from that
standpoint and i'm trying to get rid of
things
so most of it gets given away it's just
i i'd rather you didn't send me i'm sure
the merch is great but
i have so many t-shirts way more than
enough please don't send me stuff
keep the carbon footprint down and i
think yes we we will see a realignment
of the us with our historical
historical allies if and when if and
when joe biden wins
um let's see what else we've got adriana
says the tomlinsons in erie pennsylvania
want trump to go home
understood steven says i understand your
concern about early voting however check
this link they have up-to-date numbers
and some states have more info than
others i will do that
that's ghastly says has public health
failed obesity
now affecting covet 19. yeah yeah
i think that that's a that's a simple
one um we do have a hype train happening
on twitch i want to thank a few people
who have grabbed subscriptions
tyjams713 vajou
says what new material will a golf
twitter be trying out tonight i expect
very little new material
he went to jared subscribes with the
message hi david you're cool
thank you i uh i i appreciate that
lycos says for some people for some
reason people didn't like you wearing a
mask in your orchard photo yesterday
i'm guessing the orchard farm required
mask yeah um
so i i went apple picking not long ago
and listen here's the deal i've
interviewed enough doctors on the show
to have the opinion from them
that in this situation where i'm around
a couple people that i know
and it's outdoors and it's windy on a
mountain on a hill
i know that this is not a place where
where masks are really needed
but i'm not gonna be the prick not
wearing the mask you know i understand
it's like listen when i go running and
biking
i don't think i really need a mask but
i'm wearing one because i'm a team
player you know it's just
i'm just doing it and we've got what
we've got somewhere between
six months and 10 years left of this
pandemic
and i'm a team player that's all it is i
agree with you i don't really think i
need a mask
in this scenario with the voting i don't
you know it's like i'm by myself
look at there's a couple guys over here
about 100 feet away
and my girlfriend's filming do i really
need a mask there i don't think so
i'm just a team player that's all it is
that that's all you don't need to argue
with me i'm with you guys but
and by the way here is one thing if i'm
wearing the mask i'm wearing the mask
i'm not having my nose sticking out
that's just ridiculous uh that that you
know if i'm going to wear it i'm going
to wear it fully and powerfully
thank you and welcome to used van rin
yust van rin is or yoast van rin
is new member number one today at
joinpackman.com um
okay yeah that's actually not a bad idea
i mentioned i might open the phone lines
listen if we get our membership goal
which i think is a reasonable goal
uh i'll open the phone lines and we'll
we'll cut out of the rally a little
early because they do have a heart out
and we'll open the phone lines let's do
it so uh grab yourself
a membership at joinpakman.com patreon
also counts all the info is above my
head
all the info is right up there other
super chats coming in let's see what
we've got
our friend pair tiran says antonio
banderas or danny
trejo for an interview oh that is tough
that is tough i i mean
i'd have to flip a coin let's see i'll
just toss the sharpie and see where it
points
okay pointed that way that's antonio
banderas i guess i guess i'd go for bit
i would love to interview either of them
mandy copeland says hi david watching
safely from my house though i live in
erie pennsylvania thanks for streaming
love your show
thank you uh thanks to theo hanlon and
deeper shades of house
oh deeper shades of house gifting five
subs appreciate that
the dude says trump's corona party's
about a mile from where i live i'm
pretty sure i lost brain cells just
driving by there
but i kid you not he has these idiots up
here brainwashed we need everyone to
vote erie is gonna be
too close yeah pennsylvania could be the
decider
for a lack of a better term wendy says
the mute button
is making me very happy
i don't know who you're muting okay ken
says people go to these rallies to
deceive this
receive the same coveted blessing from
god that trump did amen
pennsylvester says just got our ballots
today here in colorado
thank you david for teaching me more
about how our government functions than
i learned in school
my pleasure uh
jen mckenzie says australian here
definitely watching like it's a reality
show irony and satire are dead
danny lopez likes evo morales
in bolivia morales isn't isn't isn't
back though right i don't think
but there's dany's perspective
pablo antonio says i'm from chile and we
have elections sunday i'm so nervous
saludos hermanos cuida
thank you danny thompson says hello from
snowy minnesota we already have six
inches of heavy wet snow
here in the twin cities and the warning
goes until
10 p.m tonight all right
thank you for the weather update
appreciate that
and thanks to fifi boy for subscribing
for
four months with prime um
i do have do i have any jimmy from
philly voicemails you know i do
um there's actually a delusional like
five minute voicemail
i guess since we haven't had it for a
while
i will uh i'll play it
it's it's pretty bad stuff though jimmy
from philly
the furious trumpist who was arrested
recently actually and
asked me to promote his gofundme raising
legal defense fees
he left a five-minute voicemail i'll
just play we'll just like
jump into it right in the middle okay
and see what what he's ranting about
and you let him take a review on
vacations
i don't know david i mean i guess i
guess you don't
have many to choose from in the
progressive uh
era i think jimmy dore beats the balls
off
of all he is in there yeah i actually
recently had an interesting call
with um guess i shouldn't say who it is
but basically over the last six months
the the david pakman show youtube
channel
i didn't even know this but some people
who follow the space
told me we've essentially eclipsed
all other channels but the young turks
from the standpoint not only of
subscribers
like you know people that do the type of
show i do obviously there's millions of
youtube
tens of thousands of youtube channels
that are bigger but in the progressive
left youtube space uh
in terms of views per day which really
matters and subscribers we're crushing
it so i don't know what you i don't know
how uh
exactly jimmy dore is doing but i don't
know that it's that well
and let's face it tim paul was crushing
you tim pulls on the right i mean he's
doing a totally different thing
but what i fail to understand is every
time you get together with tim
tim pull he's like a [ __ ] fangirl
why i mean this he's a fan girl i mean
i've i've
got to i think i've done something with
tim pool once
i don't know what every time means this
kid
dominates you as far as the truth is
concerned i mean he's
fairly objective it took him a while to
come around to trump but
why why he gives you all this undeserved
respect
it's just i don't know yeah jimmy seems
like he's on a different medication
that's true i i definitely agree with
that
uh okay so anyway that's your daily
daily month
ev every other month jimmy from philly
for p people ask and i deliver so that's
that
um if you're just joining us trump's
scheduled to be doing a rally in erie
pennsylvania
right now and based on when he left the
white house i assume
he is within five or so minutes of
landing
i have i'm going to be here with you
guys until 8 pm and i've made a deal
which is if we get to our membership
goal of 50 members
and or patrons i will do 15 minutes of
phone lines via
the discord at davidpakman.com discord
while the rally is going on and avery
smith just signed up
at joinpacman.com whoa what was that
and is new member number two at
joinpakman.com
and uh maybe maybe we'll get some phones
if not we'll probably do it um
after the debate thursday night and we
will be here for the debate on thursday
night
okay other super chats that are coming
in
let's see what i missed um
dustin brown says i've already voted for
biden and jamie harrison
and we'll be hiking trails all election
week what would your ideal way
to relax on election night well i'm
going to be covering it so
it's not something i've even considered
unfortunately
thomas says erie is known as the mistake
on the lake so it's fitting trump is
here again you'd be surprised at the
amount of bootlickers here
yeah i've been hearing about that in
fact about uh
about erie unknown prodigy says you're
going to pass the young turks as well
you will be the top progressive channel
very soon no no no i think tyt has five
million subscribers
uh if it's put it out of your
out of your head ladies and gentlemen it
is it is not happening what is happening
is a level 5 hype train on twitch
which i appreciate thanks to deep
freck snuggles pr
smoker bob trahan
i already thanked fifi boy okay
very good no people asking i was not
guys
my i am not nearly big enough on twitch
to be invited to do the aoc
among us stream uh i believe it's
our friend of the show this is not a
joke friend of the show
pokemane i'm sure you all remember when
she watching
a video of mine wearing a pulse uh uh
meter had recorded an elevated pulse you
guys may remember that about pokemane
and uh hassan you know these are far
bigger streamers than i am on
on twitch there is no way i jokingly
responded yesterday
to let's actually see if we can find
that tweet
um yesterday when when aoc posted about
that
oh by the way did you guys see this rip
very good dog wearing a david pakman
show uh
sweatshirt or t-shirt yeah sweatshirt
this is a very very good boy
um but in any case yesterday let me see
here
um where was it
i responded let's set it up to aoc which
is crazy just responding to aoc somehow
4 100 people like the tweet but no i was
not
i was not invited by the way though
we're on tick-tock
i did not understand the comedic
potential of uh
of of duets i kind of like them this is
a guy i know it looks like a pigeon
prison uh jumpsuit it's just a yellow an
orange polo
check this out giving a middle income
tax cut very soon as soon as we
win we're giving a middle income tax cut
it'll be a very substantial middle
income tax cut
and i've already done this i like this i
win
i give out a tax cut well why do you
need
to win why not do it now or why didn't
you already do it well i've already done
it wait so
if you've already done it why are you
doing it again
incoherent no detail just like
i i must remind you in august
donald trump was interviewed by chris
wallace in that interview
donald trump said in two weeks we are
signing
a new health care system into law that
was in early august
two weeks have come and gone four weeks
have come and gone okay anyway so
there's we're on tick tock um and
actually the tick tock thing is
interesting because we've
all we've done is post some random clips
and we have a little bit of a following
on tick tock that i think is
significantly younger younger people
which i love um
which is which is uh compelling
compelling stuff
okay other super chats coming in
let's see jules says in the uk we're in
the midst of a second wave that's
nothing we're in the midst of a third
wave
country heading towards full lockdown
again prime minister taking action dread
to think what's ahead for the usa yeah
it's going to get pretty bad here
morgan says i'm afraid that will
unemployment people will have less to
lose and put us at higher risk for civil
unrest do you agree
i think you're saying more people
unemployed will be free to go and
protest that may be true
that may be true eust van rin
says thanks for the mention from the
netherlands i'm loving your coverage
since you were struggling with the
pronunciation oh it's
yoast von rain jost von rain
yes yost von rain signed up at
joinedpakman.com
julie dawson signed up at
jointpakman.com and his new member
number three
leah vaughn signed up at
joinedpakman.com
and is new member number four thank you
i very much appreciate that
debbie says david when will you
incorporate drumming into your political
commentary let's see them grooves yeah
that that's something to think about
sir fortnight sir who do i sound like
sir gotta love minnesotans i know you're
talking politics but here's the weather
love y'all's work keep it up thank you
la pjay says
brazil tell me what it feels like to
have your father home
i'm telling you that even as the years
pass we're never going to forget
i don't know what that is about like i
understand the words
i don't know what this person is talking
about is that a reference to some uh
i i'm sorry guys i have no clue what
that's about
okay alexander says
trump ran out like a baby of a 60
minutes interview today and is crying
about it on twitter i saw that
i saw that it's pathetic really really
pathetic stuff
big thank you to turtle
snuggles noodle mixing sound
and a whole bunch of other people colors
atk
supporting the stream over on twitch
although i'm not seeing any messages
being sent to me along with that
support that's okay tristan mccoppen
says what cheating is going on right now
by republicans that we need to know
about
we're putting together a list of reports
probably for the show
tomorrow um
and i will have that for you before you
know it
let's see uh vaush says
is this the vows people have been
telling me to talk to good luck with the
rally we should talk sometime if
possible
wow uh is can people tell me is this the
vouch that people mentioned during the
stream
it's not okay all right well oh it is
it is it's not i don't know all right
very good well
let's uh let's let's look into that i
appreciate the support vaush thank you
very much
and uh we're gonna have quite a rally
here quite a quite a rally
um and again the plan is if you're just
joining i've got a duck out at eight
um i have a we call it a hard out in the
business
i don't know what business and certainly
not what i'm part of but in the business
we call it a hard out
um so my thought is i'm guessing trump
will arrive
soon and we'll get about a half hour of
the rally if we get to our
member goal we have a brand new i mean
this thing is like
off the assembly line discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let me see how many people we
even have on it right now
2 240 members so it's a relatively small
community in the sense that like reddit
now is huge we have almost 25 000 people
on our subreddit
the the discord is small enough where
there's more of a uh can we say personal
personal treatment i guess my thought
was
maybe 10-15 minutes before i have to run
we will mute the rally
and hear from some of you guys so if
you're interested in that
certainly grab yourselves a website
membership let's see what's happening on
the discord uh
a lot of different things okay well no
problem
and there's also a memes if you have
memes you want on the stream a lot of
people are unsure how to get them to me
putting them on the discord is actually
perfect we have a memes sub
community and anyway what the hell am i
talking about
all right let's see what else we've got
william borger says any thoughts on the
nbc poll saying 50
of families report being better off now
than four years ago we talked about that
on today's bonus show actually
yeah so take a look at that joe rader
says i can confirm it snowed very
powerfully in minnesota today ordered
snow tires for my electric vehicle
yeah i'm keeping uh i have an electric
vehicle as well it's all-wheel drive
and i don't i have never had i live in
massachusetts
supposedly you know what i'm talking
about and
um i've never i always have had all
seasons i've never had a vehicle where i
was putting different
tires on in the winter and i don't plan
to right now but what i am noticing
is that even with it just being a little
colder
um battery consumption has increased i'm
wondering if other electric vehicle
owners have experienced the same thing
and when i googled it it seems to it's
not like just my car
it seems to be a common uh a common
thing
okay i'm being told that again the
discord
link is not working davidpakman.com
discord um no it is working
davidpakman.com
discord is working as far as i see
so yeah okay very good
uh insurance nerd says the brazil
comment was about soccer oh okay so i'm
guessing diego was diego maradona
hugh hundo says talk to vaush olga says
watching in the hospital after surgery
thanks so much
well wishes olga uh i know you've been
around for a while on on the streams i
hope you are doing well
and quick recovery get well soon
sheila turanen is new member number five
today
and corey darathi is new member number
six very much appreciate that
uh yeah people confirming the the
discord link is working it seems to be
working very very well
i know a lot of people want me to talk
about tulsi and how tulsi gabbard
uh promoted a project veritas
[ __ ] and excuse sorry i know there's
kids that watch
and um what else did she do
she did like a prager you thing and
people want me to now
you know come out and say david you know
you got to give yourself the pat on the
back that tulsi was ridic you know from
the get
i don't feel any need to i know i've
been vindicated i just don't think she
does it
just she's not interesting to me she's
not interesting people you know it's
like i'm really glad that the sycophants
have gone away
someone sent me a crazy video the other
day
i don't i don't know who it was but
someone wrote to me or maybe this was on
the subreddit
and they said david there's this tulsi
fanatic who's had
like basically everything they've done
for the last three years has been tulsi
tulsi tulsi
and they just appeared on i think it was
oan
or some other nutty place uh
taught like as a le i don't even know
what it was but it was like someone who
completely jumped the shark
to uh take a phrase out of john hines
uh lexicon uh anyway
you know tool see give me give me a
break guys come on
okay um brandy buck says i think it's
pronounced
oh it sounds hebrew the osh like with
the little
you know the uh it's i it's not an
imposter it's not actually an apostrophe
but
um it looks like an apostrophe in the uh
hebrew alphabet
the oush no i'm sorry the ash
okay kyle hopper also weighing in on
the ash david buckley says hi david are
trump's rallies shorter seems like they
used to go on forever before no no
i'm just cutting them off early they're
still going quite long
james montalvano also wants a vaash
pakman discussion with getrick says my
wife told me today
sir you shouldn't give money to this
pacman guy i told her
sir it's worth it for independent
journalism yeah
um after trump said that melania refers
to him as sir
i've been insisting that uh that that my
girlfriend referred to me as sir as well
she's not doing it
but i'm at least insisting bob stephanie
is new member number seven today at
joinpacman.com
very much appreciate that
um what else do we have going on
a lot of different things sir i said
slow the testing down yeah
uh okay people asking about the schedule
for thursday i am
i'm streaming the debate on thursday and
uh
the debate starts at 9 00 p.m eastern my
thought is i'll kick it off around 8 15
or 8 30 p.m eastern time so we've
already set up an event on
youtube and i will be live on twitch
i'll be live on facebook
and we'll just you know we'll we'll see
how it goes i am very much looking
forward to it
post sinatra says
you realize that this isn't the world
series yeah no no this is a political
stream
bronx bjorn says i can give you a reason
why you should talk to vaash he's a
voice on the far
far left but he thinks accelerationism
is stupid reasonable guy great at
destroying people in debates
that sounds interesting to me uh i would
actually be interested in talking with a
far left
non-accelerationist because listen
as people know i i am not a capitalist
i'm sorry i i am not a socialist
i believe in highly regulated uh i
believe in in highly regulated
capitalism
but my message to the socialists is that
for now
we really should be going in the same we
should be advocating for the same things
because if ever the united states will
become socialist
i believe it's going to go through
social democracy first
it's not going to go through a
destruction of the system
and then the installation of you know
some kind of socialist utopia or
dystopia depending on your perspective
but socialism
and so um i i think that uh that it
would be interesting to talk about that
i love this comment david your spanish
accent is terrible
you sound like an argentinian yeah
that's that's how we talk
you guys understand right um
by the way i so today i interviewed eric
garcetti the mayor of los angeles and
spanish
and i was i was mildly modulating my
spanish because of course his background
is i believe
i believe he's half mexican um i was
worried he wouldn't understand
my sp argentinian accent but he did fine
actually it was a great interview and
we'll
we'll be airing that on the spanish show
this weekend
uh okay what else do we have here emily
saint sir
says it's pretty it gets pretty cold
where i live and an electric taxi
company went under because they kept
having to charge the cars in the winter
yeah that's interesting
i wonder actually let's see um electric
battery cold weather
uh maybe that's just the search i need
oh my god cold weather can temporarily
reduce the range of electric vehicles
up to 40 percent when interior heaters
are being used oh my god no wonder
they were eager to sell me the car in
the summer oh my god
that is crazy i think we'll be okay
i think we'll be okay but that is
interesting
okay the sr cone and says given
everything you know today about both
campaigns who do you think will win the
election and how will the country react
we still need to vote
listen uh this is so tough because
if if you say david even money bet who
wins i would be stupid to say trump
right because
you look at all of the data and it's
like okay if you if you force me and you
say it's just a straight money bet no
odds i i bet that biden wins
but there are many scenarios in which
trump wins
and and so that's why i think that these
are you know we've got it we've got to
be careful
about uh about making taking any action
on the basis of thinking one or the
other person is going to win
miguel palacios says the soccer
reference is a chant that the argentina
fans did during the 14 world cup towards
the brazilians
it does indeed mention diego maradona
yes i was on vacation during that world
cup
and i was watching all the games with no
audio in various sports bars
so i did not hear the chant dustin says
i feel it's an indictment on some
progressives who drew the line on tulsi
at the veritas co-sign rather than her
coziness with modi
right it's like for me the reason i
haven't talked about the tool c project
veritas and prager stuff is it didn't
change my view of toolsy
it was the same toolc we knew about the
whole time
fengari says you're a great host thanks
for the info and entertainment also
are we able to support support you via
twitch prime subscriptions of course
of course marie faire just subscribed
with twitch prime
the classy crane just subscribed
with twitch prime cd
just subscribed so a lot is happening
a lot is happening here let's see what
else we've got
andrew hodge says any interest in
psychedelics for therapeutics yeah
we did an interview with i believe it's
i know his is it rick
dobbin or rick doblin can somebody
remind me
he was on with rogan and we interviewed
him as well i'm sure someone
for some reason i'm sure someone in the
chat knows the guy's name
rick anybody know
nobody knows dublin it is doblin okay
yeah we did an interview with rick
doblin who has done a lot of research
into that
check it out on my youtube channel
flouter says hey careful
if you talk to va'ash he's banned on
twitch so keep it youtube only hope to
talk to you and discord about lindsey
graham
is the is that a case is that true where
if someone has had their channel banned
on twitch
if i interview them i could get banned
do people know
could i get banned just for mentioning
vash sorry yes okay all right so we'll
have to keep that off of uh
it's not true okay well all right we'll
see i'll talk to my twitch rep i think
um morgan kennedy says my birthday's on
the 25th all i want to do is stand in
line to vote thank you for making sense
of
all this insanity my pleasure my
pleasure
big thank you to kieran vermeulen
kieran vermeulen is new member number
eight today
miona madsen is new member number nine
melissa georgia is new member number 10
and
nathan curse is new member number 11 at
joinedpakman.com i appreciate that
oh oh oh oh that i wanted to you have to
you guys have to check out this guy this
this guy on the right i guess is like a
host for this channel
you've got to listen to this what have
they done they got to do more we need to
repeal
section 230 jim jordan needs to stop
taking money from google and get
something done
oh so oh and then and then there's i'll
just say the name jeffrey tube and
you guys know what's going on there
there all right this this channel is
completely insane
but you guys want to know what's really
crazy
look at the super chats that this this
channel get whoa hold on me voting
this super chat just while we've been
talking has pulled in
like in the 30 second the last 30
seconds it looks like they've pulled in
300
in super chats in like the last minute
isn't that absolutely insane
holy [ __ ] what are these people doing
look at that that's outrageous
okay anyway let's get off of that we are
standing by for donald trump
in erie pennsylvania
um all right let's see what else we've
got
hot mustard gas says do you think that
is any way
that congress will actually pass a
stimulus package before the end of the
year
yeah before the end of the year i do see
a way before the election
i i don't think so but before the end of
the year i do think so that that that
it's reasonable
the swordfish studio says
is unironically a communist it would be
nice to see you push back from a liberal
perspective
listen it's people push back i've
explained my perspective
if you look at the the the world over
the last 150 years
essentially um not 150
250 years we essentially have seen
the number of people living in what hans
rosling
the late great swedish uh professor and
i forget if he's a
a physicist or or what um
hans rosling has explained that if you
go uh if you divide
wealth into levels one through four
basically everybody who's watching this
right now is probably at level four you
have indoor plumbing
uh you you know you have a mobile phone
or a laptop etc
if you look at you know poverty at what
he describes as levels one two and three
which to us at level four may all look
the same
to people at level one level two looks
very different to people at level two
level three looks very different
we have seen um uh uh
the number of the percentage of the of
the world in poverty
decrease dramatically under the system
that we have
the failings that we have seen have come
not from private industry directing
resources to manufacture mobile phones
for example
i don't see any reason that the
government should be
involved in the manufacture of airplanes
nor any reason that
the airplane industry should be
socialized to common ownership but there
are certain areas that as a
society that overwhelmingly is now at
what hans rosling described
as level four uh we should take out of
the market
okay this includes health care this
includes
at least public education people want to
pay more for private you know pay for
private okay go ahead
uh and and some other areas and
when you look at uh the
failings that we have had to do better
i believe that they are failings of not
well regulated enough capitalism
not failings that would be resolved
through socializing
uh the ownership of the means of
production
uh and certainly not by you know actual
communism so that's my view i'm glad for
people to change my mind with facts
uh change my mind with facts but it's
it's like you know this is not anything
to
get get up in arms about there's no so
you know when trump says
we will never be a socialist country
there's no there's no threat of that you
know it's a it's a total straw man enemy
there's no
you know we to say we will never be
who knows what will happen in the united
states in the future
but there's no threat from socialism
it's a fake it's a straw man
uh we just need far better regulated
capitalism the likes of which
we see uh in a number of other countries
period uh okay all right wait what how
did i even get on to that i
even forgot how this started all right
let's uh let's move on oh the super chat
right all right
hot mustard gas says david would you be
willing to interview talia levin she
wrote a very good book
about infiltrating a white nationalist
online group as a jew that
sounds very interesting talia levin
um that sounds if somebody can email me
about that so i don't forget
that would be that would be cool that
sounds really interesting
oliver minshall says sir i'm concerned
that trump will win again that would be
very concerning it would
it would
uh clancy says i love getting stoned
while watching your live streams and
videos oh my god
p.s you sound like a huge nerd when you
talk about picking apples and it's great
all right other super chats
alex says hey david biden's up in the
poll seems he's got the advantage what
should we do
vote vote that's what we should do
chakaseki says we'll be smashing many
beers with my bud david grozovsky
listening to this tonight
he thanks you for pronouncing his name
correctly yesterday oh lachaim of course
absolutely
kalyn brook says hey david what do you
think caused a portion of the left to
have the idea
that bernie is leaning right or should
have made concessions for his support
you'd have to ask them you really would
have to ask them
uh people asking about the jeffrey
toobin thing that's on today's bonus
show we discussed that on today's bonus
show
so check out today's bonus show if you
don't have access to the bonus show
become a member at joinedpakman.com all
right donald trump is landing i want to
say thanks to cold as hell for the
twitch subs
colo lopez pollen cakes
see to chris rt rage all sorts of
great people signing up over on uh
over on twitch donald trump with uh
donald trump landing in erie
pennsylvania there he is
and we will hear from him shouldn't be
much more than another two hours before
we actually hear from him
all right people very very excited there
donald trump i don't know how he manages
to turn what is typically a 20-minute
flight into an hour i really don't
like we saw the plane leave i i
genuinely don't understand sometimes
when this happens
but uh yeah anyway okay nelson says if
trump does lose how long do you think it
will take to undo what he has done to
the public
that's a difficult question to answer
there are certain things that we can
undo like the time lost on climate can't
be undone
um some things can be undone by a day
one executive order by uh joe biden
so that's that's a more uh detailed
question
dana says what are the chances trump
bails out of the debate thursday
seems like he's greasing the skids i put
it at a twenty percent chance
trump bails on the debate that's how i
would uh characterize it
chakaseki says also sad that jeffrey
lubin tubin got greasy with his man meat
on a live zoom call
his apology was weird as he said he was
sorry the camera was
on yeah we talked about that on the
bonus show
shamari vazquez
the program the spanish show is on
estrella or as i say it
sundays 4p east
1p west check your local listings it's
on in about 46 or 47
different cities around the country okay
very good will get trick says i heard
melania still coughing did she not go to
walter reed no baby plasma for her i
guess
yeah melania was supposed to accompany
the mango menace tonight
but she is still ill so she is unable to
be here
unable to be here thanks to benjamin
carlson who is new
member number 12 today at
joinedpakman.com very much appreciate
the support
donald trump has landed and we are going
to hear
from uh from mango very very soon
tristan says mom in australia getting
tens of insane trump propaganda emails a
day
all different addresses that's weird
don't understand that uh
hannah was here says david my friend my
guy my dude king of podcasts
is pronounced vosh like mosh pit or
daniel tosh oh okay
wish somebody had told me that up front
i've been sounding like an idiot the
last hour
vosh vos well then spell it vosh guys
come on
uh okay matt says david david you're a
good lad and a sober voice thanks
david another uh david gore says are you
going to watch the aoc
among us twist twitch stream tonight i
am not
um when we're done i'm going to be
having dinner i've got a tv show to
watch
i'm going to be reading um yeah i'm not
i'm not going to be watching it but it
sounds like it'll be a real party
danny thompson back with more weather
reports we are officially at 7.7 inches
of snow in bloomington minnesota
also it looks like fox will be showing
trump's rally just fyi
so you know it will be somewhere other
than right side yeah we've been on the
fox stream for the last half hour
lisa says dude canadian viewer viewer
here watching the election like it's a
hockey game was wondering when you think
we will have an idea of who wins the
election
i think we actually may know on the
third
uh but almost certainly we will know by
the
friday third fourth fifth by friday the
sixth
i think we will know i really do i would
bet on that
uh not that i bet but i would i would
e says david big fan i asked you not to
speak too much during the first debate
don't hate on us tree smokers
would love to pass the j to you wow
that's aggressive
very very aggressive and geodude says i
was picking apples and new hope
pa this past weekend was dumbfounded at
the trump signs there
question
well okay i guess if you want to treat
me more formally
walid ahmed says best wishes from canada
vote vote vote
absolutely absolutely there is no
no better message than a vote vote vote
right now
kill await and tron thanks for the
twitch
subs austin mad
madgwick says another vote for you to
talk to
vosh he's an actual sensible socialist
or even more talks with steven destiny
kenny the second would be nice david
abel says david i'm not a spanish
speaker
but how does the word pendajo
right you mean pendejo sound with an
argentine accent all right guys
i mean come on guys please this is an
adult stream
storm sears says hey david love your
work are you a fan of postmodern fiction
like thomas pinchon or
jorge luis borges of course
i'm a fan of jorge luis borges and i
like pinchon as well
i've only read two of pinchon's novels
uh inherent vice of course
inherent vice and what else have i read
by pinchon
um oh bleeding edge
bleeding edge i know vineland is like
the pinchon classic that everybody
should read i've not read it i've read
bleeding edge
and inherent vice by um
by thomas pinchon by the way one of the
most interesting things about thomas
pynchon not
i know this is a trump rally and we're
supposed to talk about things like
minneapolis and ulysses s grant
but um one of the interesting things
about thomas pynchon is it's
unclear that there's any pictures of him
from the last 60 years
like there's a very interesting long
long form piece about
someone who tried to track him down in
new york city where it's believed that
he lives a very interesting reclusive
guy
fantastic author and all right twitch is
furious with me that i'm talking about
this i'm sorry
uh all right what else do we have here
mike says how much damage can trump do
to america if he loses
i'm worried he can do a lot actually
we'll talk about the transition if if
trump loses we will talk about that
tristan says my mom got spam after
joining pacman she thinks oh give me a
break guys come on you're not going to
get trump spam from becoming a member on
my website
um speaking of which joe
kessel dewey's is new member number 13.
that seems like a
like a dutch name um
rabby lebreck is new member number
14 sean heffern
is new member number 15 and vincent
lindenmaier is new member number 16.
okay guys here's the deal let me do my
my one membership pitch per stream
i am asking you right now to get a
membership on my website
okay we have all these different revenue
sources i believe
in diversification to protect me from
adpocalypse to protect me from all these
different things
all these different platforms they take
they take they take
okay they're taking slices to quote
andrew andrew yang
when you get a membership on my website
we pay 2.9 percent to process the credit
card or debit card
and we keep the rest nobody can
algorithmically demonetize me we did get
a ddos attack
during a stream a few months ago but i
believe we fixed that
and you get an extra show every single
day so people are saying david david
you got to talk about jeffrey tubin we
did on the bonus show which our members
get
david david david you got to talk about
what was the other thing i was supposed
to talk about i don't remember
anyway we talked about it on the bonus
show and
most importantly uh you are
um allowing me to be a good employer
health insurance for employees
working on retirement plans for employee
all you know i want to be a good
employer
and the coupon code above my head
2020 now saves you 66
there's rumors people have been jailed
because the discount is so huge
i think that's very unlikely to happen
to be perfectly frank it's an immoral
discount but
legal in many states and as i said
uh everybody who signs up will get a
thank you from me so for example
meeks m meeks m just signed up
and is new member number 17. boom
uh who's this jason ayers just signed
up and his new member number 18 kablooey
okay i know you guys understand that and
uh a lot of very very exciting things
going on
okay yeah people are asking about the uh
50 cent and um ice cube i think have
said they're voting trump
i don't have much to say about it it's
just like
they think their taxes will be lower
under trump and and they
probably will and so they're voting for
trump it's very very simple that's all
that's all it is um okay
oh oh oh i have a possible new theme
song
this is very this is very very different
okay
i'm gonna pull on a second let me
actually
let me take care of something here
whoa hold on uh all right as we wait for
donald trump
this is a totally different style theme
song
that jr made this is go oh
hold on this is going folk style okay
take a listen to this this is nice
[Music]
did you hear the news
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
is
[Music]
so listen i i think obviously you know p
some people are not liking it it's
not plasma it's not beta male
um but i think it's um i think i think i
like it
i think it has a lot of uh really clever
elements and it's a totally different
style which i love we love different
styles all right
we are waiting for donald trump juan
rodriguez is new member number 19
today i also want to say thanks to storm
sears whose new member number 20.
toma mundo is new member number 21
and sophie doss is new member number
22 22 reminder i'm here
uh i i'm really only here until eight
maybe i can push it until 8 05 or 8
ten trump is so late that i don't know
how much of this we're gonna get to see
but uh but we will get to see some of it
austin is asking me
if i saw nick lutzgo's twitter song
about don jr that was how we got
off on songs i did not see it sir
fortnite
says uh-oh i lost that
um sir fortnight says rest in peace
bloomington
minnesota matt mayer says cheers david
what tv shows are you watching uh i'm on
the i'm on the newest season of the
blacklist
uh it's not the best show but james
spader is just fantastic so it's like a
kind of just a fun show
um that's what i'm watching right now
cameron daley coming in with a 160
australian dollar super chat
extraordinarily generous i really really
appreciate that
thank you cameron no not even with a
message
delta echo echo says how much would it
cost to buy the david pakman show and
rebrand with canadian content oh my god
that would cost a lot that would cost a
lot
fuzz the pie guy says keep up the great
work thanks david
matthew miller says do you think the cdc
will ever publicly be able to prove that
these trump rallies are coveted super
spreader events
we have data like for example there's a
there's a minnesota trump rally
that led to 23 known cases and
presumably some unknown cases
uh so we we have some of that data we do
dovaclin says could you please comment
briefly on biden town hall versus trump
town hall thanks in advance been a huge
fan for years
i mean listen the biden town hall got
better ratings
which i don't really care about but it
also was substantive you know it's like
the the the trump town hall was
manic it was totally out of control the
biden town hall was substantive
it's you know i could feel my blood
pressure go down when we switch to the
biden town hall
i think is the the best way to say it
what's up my homies says did you hear
about fbi investigating threatening
emails sent to democrats in florida i
did not
but i will look into it matty ice says i
discovered my mail carrier carrier is
into queue last week uh-oh
he refuses to wear a mask in our
building and talks loudly while on
speakerphone absolutely unreal that's
horrifying
that's really really bad
um unknown prodigy says i'm passing tyt
next year i'm calling it
i don't think people understand the
mathematics of it
it's it's not a it is not a mathematical
possibility
for the next period of time okay trump
is about to come out let me see if i can
get caught up and thank everybody who
just grabbed a membership on my website
because i do
i don't want to miss anybody okay alec
johnson is number 23.
sexy waffles is number 24.
melissa murphy is number 25. earl
stoltzfus is number 26. evan alvarez
kisi is number 27.
angie wilson is number 28. melissa
murphy doubling up on patreon counts as
number 29.
michael gomez is number 30. phil
decard is uh
hold up decard that's um blade runner
right
isn't it uh is it rick decard that is
the blade runner character can anybody
uh uh confirm
anybody seen red blade runner
it is beautiful all right that's a phil
is number 31.
scott over b is number 32. aaron antone
is number 33 let me just update that a
little
melissa orenstein is number 34
taylor carro number 35 and
kieran slattery is new member number 36
love it uh we are waiting for donald
trump now
45 minutes late to this rally the plane
is here it is the little guy
the 757 uh presumably a small
airport in erie that couldn't handle the
big boy
saving a little bit of our tax money on
gas of course the trump campaign
should be reimbursing the government for
these campaign trips
i doubt they are i doubt they are
but we are waiting to hear from donald
trump
3ts carr says hey david spoke to you the
other day and forgot to mention how much
i enjoyed your interviews
how much i enjoy your interviews with
jesse lee peterson what a character yeah
jesse lee is uh he's wacky
he's wacky all right it looks like uh
donald trump is
about to make his entrance up everybody
lifting up their phones i don't know
what they saw maybe they saw the door
open
whitney badgett says thanks for the live
streams appreciate them
and here is donald trump let's uh make
sure we are in full hd we are
uh let's see what the song is
how did that song become the entrance
song
for a wealthy new yorker i mean it's
it's it's totally
fake it's a total you know this is a
character
that a lot of people fell for
because his followers are idiots yeah
maybe i don't know
uh that that could be thanks to steven v
who is new member number 37 today at
joinpackman.com
kemp chalmer says when will you join our
friend jlp on the fallen state i was
supposed to be on with with jessie lee
on the fallen state last week
had a doctor's appointment a very very
strong podiatry visit
and uh it got postponed not sure on the
reschedule yet
thanks to jason rados who's new member
number 38 today at joinedpakman.com
here is donald trump very very strongly
coming in
and uh i mean just wow wow wow wow what
a powerful person and you can tell
he's the picture of health and
intelligence and i'm an idiot for saying
that yeah
the dude says he was doing hair and
makeup yeah i don't know how it is that
trump as far as i know left d.c on the
plane at six
6 35 and it's like a 20 minute flight to
erie pennsylvania 30 minutes maybe
and it's 7 45 i just i really don't
understand it it doesn't make any sense
to me
uh we've got already a maskless kid on
stage
poor kid my god oh mark meadows with no
mask you saw there i'm sure
um chaka seki wants uh david grozovsky
chastised for cheating in mario party
64.
uh and that his behavior is as
deplorable as a maga chud
that is sad oh my god look at this kid
this kid's life is ruined right here
this kid's life
that i feel this has is that child abuse
guys please
is that child abuse oh my god
this may be the most unhinged crowd
we've seen masks already down
and a kid dressed as trump on the stage
that's got to be child abuse
call child services please
oh my god that is vile
thank you very much hello erie remember
that great victory we had
always
what a victory 14 days from now
we are going to win the commonwealth of
pennsylvania and we are going to win
four more years in the white house
with your vote we will continue to cut
your taxes
cut regulations support our great police
protect our second amendment
[Music]
defend our borders keep jobs and wealth
in america where it belongs thank you
we will epic growth
and you know that have you seen what's
been going on how well
we're doing did you see the recent poll
just came out
56 of the people want to be here
not four years ago they want to be with
us in
what we're calling we're rounding the
turn on the pandemic
56 and it's a record
epic job growth safe vaccines
that quickly end the pandemic it's
ending
normal life that's all we want you know
we want
normal life normal life
it's sort of like a low energy high
energy economic year
in the history of our country why are we
so zoomed in i'm not so comfortable with
this zoo this is an election between
the trump super recovery which is
happening right now
and a biden depression if he gets
elected you will have a depression
the likes of which you've never seen
you know he's gonna double triple and
now quadruple your taxes i don't think
so
i think i know the people of erie pretty
well they don't like iris or biden's
plan to kill the american dream and
that's what he'd be doing
that's so stupid biden will delay
therapies postpone the vaccines no he
won't
pandemic close your schools down our
country
and by the way pennsylvania's been shut
down long enough it's open
up pennsylvania
you've got a thousand people with no
masks get your governor to open it up he
will massively raise your taxes
bury you in regulations dismantle your
police departments
dissolve our borders confiscate your
guns
second amendment no he won't oh you're
so lucky i'm president you wouldn't have
a second amendment
eliminate private health care terminate
religious liberty
destroy the suburbs i'm saving the
suburbs i knocked out the ring
there's not even a plausible case to be
made for that
like when that when one candidate says
another will raise the deficit
you can usually come up with some lame
explanation for how they would do it
there's no
plausible way biden would do any of
those things and abolish pennsylvania
energy
how many times did he say your fracking
and mining industries will be outlawed
exiled
eradicated and totally extinguished and
you know it
because it's not up to sleepy joe
it's up to the others and the party joe
biden
has repeatedly pledged to ban fracking
right you've all heard
have you heard him i wish he did but
until he got the nomination that he came
to pennsylvania he said oh
i guess it's okay it's always what they
say first
his running mate the most liberal member
of the u.s senate
sponsors the 100 i wish
think of that 100 trillion if we have
the things trump accuses biden and
kamala of are untrue and half of those
i wish were true socialist green new
deal
which would eliminate fossil fuels at
this very moment
biden's website includes a pledge to
mandate net zero carbon emissions which
means
he would end all fracking it's
aspirational i would love to end
for a year and a half he said it under
the
obama biden administration more than 40
of all coal mining jobs will be
destroyed totally gone
and you know what's happened i mean did
you see what they did to west virginia
and other places
including west virginia when they were
here don't forget
they've been here for eight years before
me if they did a good job i would have
never run
i didn't need this i didn't need this
he's doing you a favor guys
and we're doing a good job
no but it's true if they did a good job
i wouldn't have run
thank you thank you
[Applause]
very delusional
this is a lot of people there's a lot of
people
i always want the cameras to show they
never like to show they don't like
here we go that routine you can hear how
big these crowds are and by the way you
know in all fairness to erie
all over the country makes you feel good
all over the country
the biggest crowds anyone's ever had
bigger than what we had four years ago
bigger oh when you have to watch you
have to watch what we do to 60 minutes
you'll get such a kicker
you're gonna get a kick out of it
leslie stahl is not going to be happy
the democrat party
hates fracking they hate call good
beautiful clean call no such thing we
hate american energy and joe biden will
shut it all down he's going to tonight i
want to uh
do something i want to give you this is
an original donald trump
broadway play and i had it done
specifically first time i've ever
pulled it out i had it done specifically
for the people of erie because you guys
what energy
you like being energy independent do you
like that
energy doesn't that stuff we don't need
all these faraway lands and everything
else we are now
energy independent and we're going to
keep it that way take a look at this
clip we had it made up and i think
you're like
first time i've ever done he's playing
clips now go ahead wherever it is put it
up would there be
any place for fossil fuels including
coal
and fracking in a biden administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated and no
more subsidies
for either one of those i guarantee you
that's different than banning it no more
no new fracking i'd gradually move away
from frackie
how is that banning
they want to phase out fossil fuels and
we're going gonna phase out fossil fuels
that's great
trump playing clips now at rallies
[Applause]
and what we don't show is his more
current version oh yes we'll have
fracking
and the fake news they don't do anything
about it they don't even talk to him
about it
[Laughter]
but right now he's got bigger problems
than fracking i think
you know what it's called movie night at
a rally the laptop
from hell the laptop that has
totally backfired on them wow
to all the people of pennsylvania here
this warning
if biden's elected he will wipe out your
energy industry
you have a million jobs just like he
wiped out you're stealing hey cameron i
appreciate the support but we we can't
your message is not something we can
have up on the screen so i had to get
rid of it
i apologize but we i'm sure you can
understand we can't have
super chats like that up on the screen
because you are going to reject
the radical left the united states
and i say it and i'll say it a thousand
times
the united states will never be a
socialist
nation
[Applause]
[ __ ]
think of it here we are in erie people
as far
as the eye can see look at that i mean
that's something to brag about right now
great honor
it's a great honor for all of us we're
all in this together
we're all in it as long as i'm president
we will remain the number one producer
of energy
anywhere in the world you know we're now
number one in the world with
pennsylvania
you texas we have some great how about
north dakota does a great job north
dakota
oklahoma so many different ohio does a
phenomenal job
phenomenal a couple of ohioans
and they have to have the fracking and
they have to have the energy and we need
the energy
and you know you look imagine in 2020
running on more fracking two dollars a
gallon and less you didn't think you
were going to see that
that's like a tax cut and at the same
time our energy
industry is is vibrant last year i
visited the shell
petrochemical plant in beaver county
beautiful place just
investment in your state's history our
opponents will put it out of business
they want to put it out of business
i don't think that's a great idea joe
biden has made a corrupt mark in
exchange for his party's nomination
he's handed control of his party over to
socialists
and they're full of enrage and scorn
for the middle class and for everyone
someone named one marxist controlling
joe biden please
the biden harris kamala you like kamala
the biden harris commonwealth
i'll tell you did our vice president do
a great job
i said mike that was too easy but the
biden harris agenda
is projected to slash the typical
americans
income by five 6
dollars in the wall street journal today
a nightmare for
pennsylvania family six thousand five
hundred dollars
and that's just cut it down what you
could be making
if you do this and what we're doing
because for the last
47 years joe biden has been
outsourcing your jobs offshoring your
factories
and selling out the american worker and
who knows it better than pennsylvania
right look at all the empty hulks that
you still have despite all the jobs
we've brought back america lost 10
000 factories while he was vice
president he has no clue by the way
just so you understand he has no clue
how many oh that's okay
he's a servant of the globalist
lobbyists wealthy donors
and washington vultures who got rich
bleeding american dread you know i said
the other day i never thought of it
because they're raising a lot of money
300 million
i could be the king trump's triggered by
that you can tell i would be the
greatest that ever lived the president
of the united states
all i have to do is give me a list of
the top 100 companies i'll call the
president of everyone
they will pay me whatever i want this
routine again
the problem is i'd owe them because when
they call and they have a problem
for a lot more money than we're talking
about you know it's like hard to say no
hey they were nice they treated you good
i don't want to do that i don't want to
do that we don't need the money
i don't want to do that i don't want to
go
but when you see them raise 300 350
million dollars in a month and a half
you know deals are being made just so
you understand deals are being made big
deals bills
i mean look at the deal he's making for
himself okay
but deals are being made in 2016
pennsylvania voted to
fire this depraved political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting
america first america
sick rally whether you want to hear it
or not
joe biden is a corrupt politician he's a
corrupt
politician trump's not corrupt
and smoking gun emails show that the
biden family sold the vice presidency
for a very
very substantial amount of money more
money than anybody would believe
there is no evidence of that whatsoever
while his family raked in millions of
dollars from
china and foreign nations
the bidens got rich while pennsylvania
got robbed and so did the rest of our
country
joe biden's wealth comes from writing a
book after he was no longer vice
president
kind of weird she doesn't get that we'll
own the usa
and you know it there's no way he does
anything about it
and yet media and the big tech
big tech they're desperately trying to
cover up everything they don't want to
hear speeches like this they don't want
to hear anything about it
this is a massive scandal that they're
trying to suppress
i'm not trying to find the scandal biden
sleepy joe i'm running against the
corrupt media
the big tech giants the washington swamp
and the democrat party is a part of all
of them
every single one of them they flood your
communities with criminal aliens
drugs and crime while they live behind
beautiful
gated compounds they try to take away
like trump
second amendment they want to take it
away while they enjoy
private security that's fully armed they
support crippling lockdowns like your
governor is doing
i wonder like if trump knew how
difficult it would actually be because
trump has no idea how you would get rid
of the second amendment which is by
passing one that cancels out the second
um do you think he'd still be repeating
it like if he knew how unlikely it was
that
the second amendment would be repealed
november 3rd
got to get out and vote pennsylvania you
got to get out and vote
you know if we win pennsylvania we win
the whole thing i mean it's crazy
they're saying oh it's his home state
it's not his home state he left you when
he was nine right his parents
i'm not blaming him for that but you
know he likes to go around yeah
yeah how much my home says it's not his
home state i actually went to college in
pennsylvania okay so you know i think i
got great marks
but it's not his home state he comes
from a place called delaware and he
never leaves delaware i like delaware
too
but he never is here he's making another
speech from what doesn't make too many
speeches either
he took a five-day lid you know what a
lid is i never heard lin
lid is like they put the lid like a
garbage can right they put them
he took a five-day lid i mean this guy
all he does is like
stay home you know wow
you know why because he can't take any
questions now from the press
can't take any questions how about
yesterday
yes we'll see at the debate he went to
get an ice cream
and the press is standing these are all
killers i mean they're there they are
look the fake news
they're standing here getting into the
authoritarian part of this piece
[Music]
think of me they're screaming at me like
all they want to know what flavor ice
cream do you like well i like
i like vanilla and chocolate thank you
they don't ask me those questions what a
rally
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
and that is now starting the portion of
the speech that is literally cookie
cutter so like i said guys i i've got to
run i do have to run at 8 pm eastern
um i do appreciate everybody who joined
me if you believe
uh that it is important to see the rest
of this by all means you can continue
without me uh but i will be back with
everybody tomorrow remember you can
continue the discussion on the subreddit
davidpakman.com
reddit also on the brand new shiny
out of the rapper discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's hope
we don't have four more years of this
but if we do we'll we'll get through it
together at least that's my hope